USED AND KILLED THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HALFWAY
THROUGH THE DAY IN THE PRIVATE
RESORT IN FLORIDA AND HE'S BEEN
KEEPING TABS ON WASHINGTON AND
GETTING IN A TWITTER SPAT WITH
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AND
SHE HOLDS ONTO THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
A CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON IS
DOWN IN WEST PALM BEACH
FOLLOWING THE PRESIDENTS WERE
MR. TRUMP IS TARGETING A
FAMILIAR FOE.
A GOOD EVENING, RICH.
>> GOOD EVENING, BY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
SPEAKER PELOSI SHOULD FOCUS ON
HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
HE'S ABOUT THE MIDWAY POINT OF
TWO WEEKS HERE IN FLORIDA AND HE
HAD THE UNCERTAIN THE
IMPEACHMENT FUTURE AHEAD.
SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS, "THE FACTS
ARE CLEAR AND EVERY WITNESS TOLD
THE SAME STORY DESPITE THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTEMPTS TO COVER IT
UP, PRESIDENT TRUMP ABUSED HIS
POWER FOR HIS OWN PERSONAL GAIN.
HASHTAG DEFEND OUR DEMOCRACY."
THE IMPASSE IS NOT OUR DULL MY
BROKEN, THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT, AND THEN WENT TO
RECESS PERIOD OF HOLDING THEM
FOR THE SENATE, SHE IS LIVING IN
LIMBO IF OR WHEN THE TRIAL WILL
BEGIN.
IF SHE SAYS SHE'S TELLING THE
CHILD TO
COMPELLED SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL TO ALLOW FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY.
THEY SAY THEIR STONEWALLING END
OF THE PRESIDENT AND THEN
ESTIMATION OFFICIALS DID NOTHING
WRONG FOR SPENDING A TWO
UKRAINE, THEY SHOULD HAVE NO
PROBLEM TESTIFYING ABOUT IT.
>> IT BE I'M PRESIDENT FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE IN THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL THAT WILL
DECIDE ON WHETHER THE PRESIDENT
IS CONVICTED AND REMOVED FROM
OFFICE DID NOT HEAR ANY
WITNESSES.
THE IMPEACHMENT 41 WITNESSES,
PRESIDENT CLINTON'S IMPEACHMENT,
31 WITNESSES.
>> THE SPEAKER AND HOUSE
DEMOCRATS RUSH TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT AND THAT THEY ARE
DELAY TACTIC IS THE LATEST PROOF
THAT THIS IS A POLITICAL
CHARADE.
>> SHE'S CURRENTLY HOLDING A
LIVE GRENADE, THEY'VE PULLED
THAT PINOUTS, AND THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
>> TWO-THIRDS OF THAT SIZE
ENTERS WILLING TO CONVICT AND
REMOVE THE PRESIDENT AND THAT'S
THE CONSEQUENCE IN THE ELECTION
YEAR FOR CRYING OUT LOUD.
AS A CONSEQUENCE, WE KNOW HOW
THIS ENDS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP COMPLAINED
THAT IT'S A DISTRACTION MAKING
DEALING WITH FOREIGN LEADERS
MORE DIFFICULT.
IF A FOREIGN POLICY DISPUTE
EMERGED, AND PRESIDENT RODRIGO
WILSON FORMALLY DECLINE ANY
VISITATION TO VISIT THE
UNITED STATES.
THE COUNTRY IS BANNING TWO U.S.
SENATORS, DICK DURBIN AND
PATRICK LIKE YOU'VE COME UP FROM
TRAVELING PHILIPPINES.
THEY ALSO SAID IT COULD REQUIRE